we begin with breaking news out of New
York Hollywood movie producer Harvey
Weinstein has been found guilty of
sexual assault and third-degree rape but
he's been acquitted on the most serious
charges
Kristen sube is live for us in New York
Kristen just asked a little bit more
about these charges and about the
verdicts right well as you mentioned the
two most serious charges predatory
sexual assault he was found not guilty
but he was found guilty of rape in the
third degree and sexual assault a
criminal sexual assault those two
charges relate to allegations of two
women one an actress one a production
assistant who said that they were forced
into this relationship with Harvey
Weinstein the defense had argued that
this was a consensual relationship and
they pointed to emails and other
evidence that showed that both women
maintained a relationship with Harvey
Weinstein after the alleged attacks
occurred even at times of flirtatious
relationship and the sexual relationship
with him but the jury took the
prosecution's argument and their account
into their point of view as they decided
that he was in fact guilty of those
charges the predatory sexual
predatory sexual assault charges would
have required that the prosecutor showed
a pattern of abuse over the years and
the jury was not willing to go that far
we found out on Friday that they had
questions on that charge and that they
were split on that today they came back
unanimously to say that they did not
have enough evidence to find him guilty
that would have required that they
believed the story of an actress who
took the stand Annabella skiore who
alleged that she was raped back in the
90s in her hotel room by having Harvey
Weinstein she testified emotionally
before the court very high-profile
actress who played in The Sopranos
but her situation occurred in the mid
90s which is before the statute of
limitations so it was quite some time
ago and too long ago to bring charges
against Weinstein for that
case in particular but the prosecution
was hoping that her story along with
three other women who also testified
that they were raped or assaulted by him
would give them enough evidence to
convict on this higher charge which
carried up to life in prison for
Weinstein now he's still likely to do
some time and he's not clear of charges
either there's also charges pending in
Los Angeles against him as a result but
so not the full verdict that prosecutors
were hoping for but certainly some time
behind bars is now likely for for this
famous Hollywood producer and also
Kristen interestingly Weinstein was
found not guilty of first-degree rape
but guilty of third-degree rape which I
thought was an interesting outcome tell
us about the complainants in this case I
believe there were two women whose
accounts were being considered in the
trial yes the two guilty charges relate
to a an aspiring actress and a
production assistant who they say were
forced into these relationships as you
know this case against Harvey Weinstein
really prompted a national movement
known as the me2 movement there were
countless women who came forward after
reports began surfacing in the media
there had been rumors about Harvey
Weinstein being this lecherous producer
for years it was kind of circulating a
lot of media outlets did not want to
touch the story because he was just so
powerful but when some women came
forward including the actress Rose
McGowan and started talking about it on
social media it prompted women around
the country to talk about their own
cases of sexual abuse we saw people
coming out in droves outside of the
courthouse when Harvey Weinstein showed
up women's groups chanting and taunting
him because of this movement that he
inspired it really helped expose some of
the the dirty secrets of Hollywood in
many industries where men of power had
taken advance
of women and it caused so many women to
speak out that this case really
resonated and continues to resonate for
women around the country and around the
globe but again he will not face the
most severe charges the most severe
charges the jury found that there wasn't
enough evidence to convict him but a
partial victory for women who were
looking for some justice for Harvey
Weinstein my colleague Gabe Elizondo
actually has more about the history of
Weinstein's case and the movement that
he inspired Harvey Weinstein was not
just any movie producer
but maybe one of the most powerful ever
many of the greatest actors or actresses
over the past 40 years have worked with
him in some capacity either directly or
through his movie studios throughout his
career Weinstein has 81 Academy Awards
to his name and his power extended into
politics at the very highest of levels
from Bill and Hillary Clinton who called
him a personal friend to Barack and
Michelle Obama one of their daughters
briefly worked for Weinstein to Donald
Trump who often was at the same New York
events but it was Weinstein's influence
in Hollywood and his ability to make or
break an actor's career where he had his
most power and according to prosecutors
he wielded that power by sexually
exploiting women
he's been on trial in New York for
allegedly raping an aspiring actress in
2013 and sexually assaulting another
woman in 2006 for other women testified
against him saying they too were victims
more than a hundred other women many
anonymously have come out publicly and
said they too were assaulted by
Weinstein during the four week trial
prosecutors told the 12-person jury
Weinstein was a serial rapist and
manipulator his defense argued otherwise
if you look at all the evidence the
evidence shows consensual relationship
in 2017 the New York Times first
reported allegations of abuse against
Weinstein sparking women to come forward
and talking about abuse at the hands of
more powerful men actress Alyssa Milano
tweeted if you've ever been sexually
harassed or assaulted right hope me too
as a reply to this tweet thousands did
and the movement took off there were
protests throughout the US and Hollywood
celebrities launched a campaign to fight
sexual harassment in the workplace
time's up on the pervasive culture of
silence that has enabled abusers like
Weinstein the me2 movement born at a
Weinstein but the question now is where
does it go from here
as for Weinstein himself it's not over
prosecutors in Los Angeles have charged
him with rape and sexual assault of two
other women
Gabriel is Ando al Jazeera New York